il ne reste plus qu'à vous souhaiter de
bonnes vacances
moi c'est nicolas et j'aimerais bien
vous raconter mes vacances alors alors
les temps forts du cas chaque année
papas et mamans discutent de longs mois
on va passer les vacances on ira à la
bretagne à allah sait pas pourquoi il se
met dans cet état alors qu'à la fin
c'est toujours pareil la montagne à la
mer alors mais cette fois ci ça ne s'est
pas passé comme public cette année c'est
la mer sinon d'accord et on omet maman
est ce qu'on est venu faire là bas pas
c'est pas un bon mois pour pique [ __ ]
ta est très content d'être en vacances
d'ailleurs il serait beaucoup plus que
d'habitude c'est comme d'habitude parce
qu'à l'habitude elle est pas moindre
alors pourquoi tu as mis ton bonnet de
bain tu vas devenir tout de suite
maman oui mouchet c'est quoi le verbe
plaire à la deuxième personne du pluriel
subjonctif les rats non plus j'ai un an
plus tôt